and let's go now to Roman badana and he
is a Russian journalist the founder and
editor-in-chief of the investigative
journalism site proyect which has been
targeted by the Russian government and he left
Russia facing the threat of a prison sentence
Roman I'm glad to talk to you again and a moment
ago I mentioned the Nobel Peace Prize uh winning
group in Russia right one of its leaders
taken in for questioning today released on
bail for allegedly discrediting the Russian
armed forces and we've heard about a number
of similar arrests recently is Putin getting
more aggressive at this time in cracking down
yes it's absolutely correct uh in my view the
Kremlin has clearly launched a brutal new brutal
campaign against so-called internal enemies and
unfortunately I'm afraid we will soon see very
bad news of this kind from Russia more bad news
on this I mean as the stories are are obviously
horrible as they cross and the prison sentence
is being handed out I also know Roman you've
been doing some new reporting on Putin's trip
to the Russian occupied city of maripole over
the weekend right where uh he was um I mean
just looking at those buildings that's not
what maripole looks like right they would have
had to put some sort of facade on them at one
point he was heckled by someone off camera
I want to play that moment foreign [Music]
this is not true it's all for show seemingly
surprising to Putin's security detail and of
course as you know Roman there's been some talk
the Putin wasn't actually even there that it was
either somewhere else or it was a body double or
something like that this has been coming from you
know official official channels right even in
Ukraine and I know you did a lot of digging on
it what did you find yeah we did some geolocation
research and we have established that Putin was
indeed driving through maripo and moreover
our colleagues from other Russian media they
also identified some of the people who got
on the footage with Putin and these people
really live in maripole so all this in total
suggests that the visit to marry up as well
as the visit to Crimea and to the military base
and rastolph they really took place but but the
Details Matter first the visit was very secret
for example not a single journalist and Moscow
knew about the trip Putin simply didn't take them
with him second there was a very limited list of
officials traveling with Putin this suggests
that the trip was kept secret until the very
last moment and finally it's important that the
trip took place at night for the sake of greatest
safety and it showed us that the Kremlin
was really afraid of information leaks it
turns out that the Kremlin do not trust
even the official surrounding Putin
yeah I mean that's pretty incredible that they
would think that that could be a threat to him and
his safety says says so much thank you so much
Roman I'm glad to talk to you again thank you